esto implica que en los próximos dos
años que le quedan de gobierno alberto
fernández todas las decisiones van a
llevar a arduas negociaciones al
interior del legislativo cuando sea
necesario tramitar por vía legislativa
decisiones de política tal vez se elija
en algunos momentos ir por decretos de
necesidad y urgencia que es algo que
hacen muchos gobiernos en el país cuando
están trabados en el legislativo y
sienten que es urgente sacar algo
adelante pero hay otras negociaciones
que no podrán ir por ahí una como decía
es la necesidad de aprobar el acuerdo
con el fondo monetario internacional- la
aprobación de presupuestos la
designación de jueces y la designación
de fiscales generales la posibilidad por
ejemplo de hacer alguna reforma
importante a nivel judicial o impositiva
todo ese tipo de políticas y gestiones
que el gobierno quiere hacer de aquí al
final de su mandato van a ser muy
difíciles y van a forzar a negociar
fuertemente al interior del legislativo
y seguramente darle concesiones a la
oposición para poder avanzar